hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the key ideas to stoic moral
philosophy or ethics is that of living
in accordance with nature and Cato in
Cicero's on the n's book three where
he's representing the stoic school and
laying out some of its key doctrines in
a summary form is going to invoke this
at several points and he's never going
to attempt to define it as a matter of
fact one thing we ought to point out is
that the stoic conception of living in
accordance with nature is not something
simple that actually can be defined
effectively within a single phrase it's
actually quite a complex idea there are
definitions available but they have to
be put together and you might say a
composite picture in order for you to
fully understand what the Stoics meant
by that so he's more invoking the idea
than attempting to define it but there
are some very useful clarifications that
are provided in this work about just
what is supposed to go on with living in
accordance with nature before looking at
those let's talk about how this notion
of living in accordance with nature
comes up within the work so like I
pointed out this is a very important
concept it covers multiple aspects of
human development and morality and and
you know how we ought to live our life
it is an ideal for the Stoics it comes
up first in the discussion of the
primary impulses of nature every being
according to the Stoics has a sort of
rudimentary grasp of its own being its
own condition and it's also got an
affection directed towards itself for
that that being to remain in existence
and for things that conduce to that or
that allow it to grow that allow it to
be healthy
allow it to develop twos you have being
and more of it you might say there's
also correlative Lee a reaction against
an NA antipathy directed against those
things that would lessen its being that
would lead to its destruction that would
impede it in some way and there's even a
a sort of directed impulse against its
own destruction so that is a basic thing
and that is in accordance with nature
you can call this self log or self
affection if you want it involves
perception of self Cicero has Cato go a
bit further and he says with human
beings we can grasp the order or doe in
in Latin right and the harmony the
Concordia a very important term of the
universe but also of our actions and how
they can be arranged in relation to each
other this means we can also grasp the
opposites disorder lack of harmony or
active discordance
and we have this similar affective
relation towards those we come to
appreciate order and harmony and see our
own place in it and when we do that we
are grasping what is also in accordance
with nature nature in a different sense
than just say the natural world of you
know the way people conceive of that
nature bloody and tooth and claw or
anything along those lines or when
people do bad stuff oh well that's just
human nature
the Stoics would say no that's not human
nature that's damaged screwed up failed
to develop fully human nature that's not
what we take is our model when we
understand how things actually can come
together well correctly properly this is
something that the Stoics think we have
a basic grasp of and an effective
relation towards and we can choose to
follow we also sometimes screw it up and
then we realize that so understanding
that
harmony leads to realizing that the main
good for human beings doesn't lie in
something like pleasure making a ton of
money it doesn't even necessarily lie in
the health of the body it lies in
something higher the moral good the hone
s them and in actions that are in
alignment with in harmony with the moral
good the intrinsically valuable and
character dispositions or traits virtues
which are aligned with that that
expressed that from which those sort of
actions stem that is a key stoic idea
virtue is in accordance with nature
every single virtue is a distinctive way
of being in accordance with nature every
vice every bad characteristic cowardice
injustice you know lack of self-control
all those sorts of things would be out
of accordance with nature or contrary to
nature so moral action itself Cicero is
going to tell us is in accordance with
nature there are other things which are
not maybe themselves directly in
accordance with nature but lead to
what's in accordance with nature and
those things are thereby made valuable
or good because of that but they don't
possess intrinsic goodness whereas moral
action action that is in accordance with
the virtues action that is good is right
to do that is in accordance with nature
now there are some other things that he
says along the way that I think are very
helpful to keep in mind and I'm going to
refer a little bit to the Latin here
just so that you know we can sort of
keep on track and know exactly what he's
talking about there's a sort of chain
that led you know it in in one of these
passages
where he says that living in accordance
with nature following these primary
impulses there's actually a sort of
developmental process he says first we
have these these impulses themselves and
we start to use them as a criterion for
choosing and rejecting so we're living
our life in the world then we start to
live in agreement and in harmony with
nature right that provides us with this
basis and by the way Cicero is is going
to use a variety of terms to describe
these various states and you could ask
yourself do all these things mean the
same thing is living in agreement and in
harmony more than just living in
agreement or in accordance with that's a
separate topic but he does use this
phrase co-inventor cone congruent Eric
way quite often in in this work so
presumably this is a more consolidated
state and so we go from this basis to
making choices with appropriate actions
and the term that he's actually using
here is select Co we decide in a sort of
conscious way about how we live in
accordance with nature how we choose to
follow these primary impulses we do so
through appropriate action which is
Vicki oh Vicki um right and that is also
translated as duty so if you think about
the things that you ought to do or
obligation requirement the things that
fall upon you that are not themselves in
themselves necessarily the moral good
but which lead to it for you so we do
that for awhile we make these choices
and then he says it becomes a fixed
Abbot is how its translated here but the
Latin is actually a little bit stronger
they in the a at Perpetua they become
part of who we are they become fixed
stable within us and this leads to a
final state which is what he is going to
call its translated here as rationalized
and in harmony with nature this choice
and if we look at what's being said here
it's quite interesting he says to amat
extremum finally we come to the end or
the extreme konstanz consenting to a
knot or a right and what does this mean
the consent tonic wave means we're
conscious of this this is something that
we give a cent to we say yes to over and
over again it's easy for us to say yes
to it because we're doing the right
thing and we've recognized it as the
right thing it's also konstanz it's
stable it is what can be expected of us
so rationalized that does make sense to
say here it is something that we can in
fact say this is the rational thing to
do if somebody asks us to do it we don't
think about it every single time but if
we do think about it we're like yeah
that that is the right thing to do if
somebody challenges us and it becomes
something that is in harmony with nature
right so this in harmony with nature
isn't a simply punctual thing where
we're doing it I'm in harmony with
nature here I'm in harmony with nature
here I've been harmony with nature here
eventually our actions and our choices
become an entire context that helps
maintain ourselves in accordance with
nature as the Stoics understand it
there's one other thing that I do want
to point out and this comes sort of
towards the end of book 3 he tells us
that we do need to study what he calls
natural philosophy
now you might think here we're talking
about the natural sciences like you need
to study chemistry or biology natural
philosophy covered a much wider range
for the ancients and it included what we
would call today psychology so we need
to understand how our minds how our
motivations how our basic structures
work and it tells us that here here we
find a little bit more clarification of
this notion of in accordance with nature
that the person who wants to live in
accordance with nature must base their
principles on the system and government
of the entire world so that means that
we need to have a knowledge of the plan
of nature there's also a theological
component here for Cato the life of the
gods and of the answer to the question
this is a key question whether the
nature of human being is or is not in
harmony with that of the universe so
there's the harmony there's there's
being in accordance with the harmony
with the workings of nature as a vast
totality right not getting upset about
the fact that when I dropped a book into
the bath the the pages get wet because
that's the natural order cause and
effect right that's one part of being in
accordance with nature and then there's
distinctively human nature where we can
talk about moral action and grasp of the
good as such and self-consciousness and
doing philosophy in the first place and
there's a fundamental question that the
Stoics have an answer to is the heart is
the the order of the whole of nature
capital n is that possible to harmonize
with human nature and for the Stoics the
answer is yes but it means that we as
human beings have to make choices to
align ourselves as the individual beings
that we are who are probably kind of
damaged and screwed up with both human
nature and the nature of the whole which
means that we need to devote some study
to it
so he says that you know with
out studying natural philosophy to some
degree we're probably going to be a bit
handicapped in this so that covers what
we get in this picture of in accordance
with nature here in on the ends book
three it's not the entirety of the stoic
view on that but this has already
covered quite a few important points
about it
you